voy a dibujar aquí un triángulo un lado
va a ser en color azul otro lado base el
color naranja y el tercer lado va a ser
color rosa y voy a llamarle a los
vértices a b y c este de aquí va a ser a
este va a ser b y este va a ser se lo
que queremos hacer en este vídeo es
obtener algunos postulados o criterios
que nos permitan determinar si un
triángulo es semejante al triángulo a b
c vamos a empezar con algunas cosas que
tengan que ver con ángulos imaginemos
que este triángulo aquí tiene un ángulo
de 90 grados que acá tiene un ángulo de
30 grados 30 grados y de este lado tiene
un ángulo de 60 grados 60 grados bueno
si tuviéramos otro triángulo con los
mismos ángulos entonces definitivamente
serían triángulos semejantes ya habíamos
platicado eso en vídeos pasados es decir
si aquí tuviéramos un triángulo x si
vamos a ponerle así jay-z de modo que
esté fuera de 90 grados vamos a ponerlo
en color rosa esté fuera de 90 esté
fuera de 30 y esté fuera de 60
entonces estos dos triángulos
definitivamente serían semejantes es
decir el triángulo el triángulo a veces
sería semejante al triángulo x y z y es
importante que las letras sean las
letras correspondientes verdad en a
tenemos el ángulo de 30 en b y en jet
tenemos el de 97 y en zeta tenemos el de
60 bueno entonces aquí tenemos dos
triángulos semejantes porque tienen sus
tres ángulos correspondientes
congruentes pero mi pregunta es
necesitamos los tres ángulos o podremos
hacerlo con dos bueno pues yo tengo que
tan solo teniendo dos ángulos
correspondientes iguales podemos
concluir que los triángulos son
semejantes déjame borrar esto de acá
vale y supongamos que tenemos nada más
estos dos ángulos correspondientes
iguales éste es de 30 y este es de 90
que podemos hacer aquí esto será
suficiente para concluir que son
semejantes pues sí porque en un ángulo
la suma en un triángulo la suma de los
ángulos de 180 y aquí ya tenemos 30 y 90
el tercer ángulo tiene que ser de 60
porque es de 120 nos faltan 60 para
llegar a 180 así tan solo teniendo estos
dos ángulos tenemos que el tercero
también es igual y por lo tanto los dos
triángulos son semejantes muy bien
entonces ese va a ser nuestro primer
criterio de que se me cansa o bien
postulado de semejanza lo voy a poner
aquí postulados
postulados de semejanza semejanza vale
entonces nuestro primer postulado de
semejanza es el postulado aa
y esto quiere decir que para ver qué dos
triángulos son semejantes basta ver que
dos ángulos correspondientes son
congruentes bueno ahora vamos a hablar
un poco acerca de proporciones
imagínate que aquí tenemos déjame borrar
y aquí los nombres porque voy a volver a
usar estas letras pero imagínate que
tenemos otro triángulo va entonces vamos
a poner por aquí otro triángulo
ok que también parece semejante a este
triángulo ahora le vamos a pedir que las
parejas de lados correspondientes tengan
la misma proporción es decir vamos a
pedirle que y aquí voy a usar las letras
x y z x y z vamos a pedirle que la razón
entre ave y xy ave entre xy esta de acá
sea igual a la razón de veces entre
jay-z sea igual a la razón de bs entre
eta y que eso de ahí también sea igual a
la razón de la tercera pareja vale la
tercera pareja es decir sea c
entre zx bueno pues como platicábamos en
el vídeo anterior estoy aquí también es
una condición suficiente para que los
dos triángulos sean semejantes vale a
esta condición de las razones le vamos a
llamar el criterio l l
entonces lo voy a apuntar por acá ese es
nuestro segundo criterio el criterio lll
y hay que tener cuidado de no
confundirlo con el criterio lll de
congruencia en congruencia pedimos que
los lados sean iguales entre sí esté
igual a éste este igual a este está
igual a éste a quien semejanza sólo
pedimos que las tres razones sean
iguales entre sí y vaya que los lados
sean proporcionales vale vamos a ver un
ejemplo no sé imagínate que este lado de
acá y de digamos 30 que este lado de acá
mide 60 60 entonces usando el teorema de
pitágoras podrían podemos ver que este
de acá mide mide 30 raíz de 330 a raíz
de 3 si quieres luego vemos eso cuando
platicamos de los triángulos de 30 60 90
pero bueno tenemos estas medidas y no se
imaginemos que acá tenemos que esto mide
3 raíz de 3 que este lado mide
digamos 3 y este lado mide 6 de 6 vale
entonces qué sucede con estas tres
razones ave entre xy sería igual a 10 es
30 a raíz de 3 entre 3 raíz de 330 entre
3 también es 10 y finalmente 60 entre 6
también es 10 vale entonces tenemos que
las tres razones son 10 y a partir de
eso podemos concluir que los dos
triángulos son semejantes vale entonces
observa no estamos pidiendo que los
lados sean iguales como para el criterio
de congruencia sino simplemente que
estén en la misma proporción bueno
entonces tenemos este criterio de
semejanza lll vamos con uno último y
para este criterio
vamos a plantear otro problema por aquí
imagínate que tenemos un triángulo abc
vale entonces voy a hacer otro triángulo
abc por acá digamos que este es a éste
es b y este es c y vamos a pensar que
ahora hay un segundo triángulo xz que
cumple lo siguiente por aquí vamos a
tener x dejan de poner por acá xy ahora
cada maestra receta y acá va a estar y
etc
vale entonces aquí va a ser x aquí y
aquí se está entonces lo que vamos a
pedir ahora es lo siguiente vamos a
pedir que xy sea cierta proporción de
ave es decir xy sea igual a cada vez es
cada vez es ave
vale eso no es difícil cualquier
cualquier longitud es una proporción de
otra longitud pero ahorita vamos a ver
qué más bueno entonces vamos a pedir que
esto se acabe se sabe vamos a pedir que
este ángulo este ángulo a veces sea
igual al ángulo xtz y finalmente vamos a
pedir que jesse tan
ez también tenga esta proporción cada
acá con respecto al lado b s con
respecto al lado vece entonces estamos
pidiendo este lado proporcional a éste
en la misma razón que este lado sea
proporcional a éste y además que el
ángulo de en medio de los dos lados sea
el mismo con esto podremos concluir que
x es eta y a veces son semejantes o sea
podemos concluir que x y z
el triángulo x y z es semejante al
triángulo al triángulo abs en abc bueno
pues yo digo que sí porque observa o sea
al pedir esta condición estamos diciendo
que xy debe tener una medida específica
y aquí estamos diciendo que jay-z debe
tener una medida específica
entonces el triángulo ya está totalmente
determinado porque aquí tenemos una
medida específica aquí también y el
ángulo debe de ser igual a este ángulo
de acá entonces justo xz también debe de
estar en esta proporción acá con
respecto a hace vale bueno entonces a
este tercer criterio le llamamos el
criterio l
l
el a él se llama así porque tenemos una
pareja de lados proporcionales en la
misma razón que otra pareja verdad y
además el ángulo entre esas parejas es
el mismo este ángulo es igual a este
ángulo de acá pero misma idea antes
teníamos un criterio de congruencia l
que nos pedía que el l bueno que los
lados sean congruentes aquí nada más son
aquí nada más es que sean semejantes
vale déjame ver un ejemplo por aquí
abajo entonces no sé imagínate que
sabemos que un triángulo tiene medidas
nos digamos 3 2 y 4 y que tenemos otro
triángulo un poco más grande un
triángulo un poco más grande con medidas
digamos 9 aquí 6 aquí y que es que este
ángulo de acá
este ángulo es igual a este ángulo de
acá entonces se observa aquí que para
pasar de 3 a 9 es razón 3 verdad es
multiplicar por 3 para pasar de 2 a 6
también es razón 3 y entonces y bueno y
este ángulo de acá es igual este de acá
y entonces usando el criterio de
semejanza el l concluimos que estos dos
triángulos son semejantes y la
justificación es más o menos la
siguiente o sea definitivamente hay un
triángulo que es semejante a este en
razón 3 vale y bueno no puede ser muy
distinto a éste porque b debe de tener
este lado igual a 9 debe de tener este
ángulo y debe de tener este lado igual a
6 porque estamos multiplicando por tres
entonces este triángulo que existe que
es semejante a éste debe de ser
exactamente este triángulo de aquí y
bueno eso se puede ver con criterios de
congruencia pero no me quiero meter
mucho en eso finalmente podemos ver que
hay otras restricciones que no ayudan
mucho por ejemplo si tuviéramos un
triángulo que aquí mide 9 y que aquí
mide 4 vale entonces por mucho que este
ángulo sea igual a éste
y el tercero no pueden ser semejantes
porque este lado está en razón 3 con
este y éste está en las son 2 con este
entonces este no podría ser un triángulo
semejante al primero y finalmente aunque
tengamos los dos lados que necesitamos o
sea que éste me da 9 y este me da 6 si
el ángulo del medio no es igual o no
sabemos que es igual
tampoco podemos concluir nada vale
entonces en este caso tampoco tampoco
tenemos triángulos semejantes y bueno a
lo mejor te estás preguntando por otros
criterios que salen de los criterios de
congruencia por ejemplo antes en
congruencia tendríamos teníamos el
criterio el criterio
a él y teníamos también el criterio el
criterio a él
pero estos dos criterios para alentar a
pasarlos a criterios de semejanza o
postulados de semejanza pues nos dan
cosas que ya teníamos por ejemplo si
tenemos los dos ángulos y un lado pues
pues ya tenemos los dos ángulos entonces
el tercer lado ya no lo necesitamos
porque caemos en este de acá y lo mismo
sucede con ángulo lado ángulo si ya
tenemos dos ángulos del triángulo
congruentes entonces otra vez caemos en
este caso y en realidad de estos lados
de aquí no servían para nada vale bueno
entonces estos de aquí a a él él y él a
él van a ser nuestros tres postulados de
semejanza o criterios de semejanza y
bueno nada más como un recordatorio me
gustaría insistir en este punto de que
el él no quiere decir que los lados sean
congruentes sino simplemente que estén
en la misma proporción y el mismo
comentario para este de acá vale l l
sólo es que esta pareja de lados está en
la misma proporción que esta pareja de
la